he was great i think you know people can
sometimes just be a little bit unkind
and i wish they weren't friends the
reunion director
ben winston speaks out after viewers
take to social media to share concerns
and questions about matthew perry's
health
it's a very loving tight-knit group
and when we see each other it's a it's a
very heartwarming thing
on friday ben appeared on the hollywood
reporters tv's top 5
podcast and responded to all the online
chatter
specifically about matthew's seemingly
slurred speech
he was great i think you know people can
sometimes just be a little bit unkind
and i wish they weren't he was great i
loved working with him i think he's
a brilliantly funny man and uh i thought
he had some great one-liners in the show
and yeah i felt just happy to lucky to
be in his presence and directing him on
something like this
friends executive producer and director
kevin bright
also weighed in on the comments in a
separate interview with the hollywood
reporter
quote what people say is what people say
i don't have anything to say about that
except it was great to see him and i
think he's very funny on the show
but yes i think he's okay he seemed
stronger and better since the last time
i saw him
and excited about going forward matthew
has opened up about his health battles
in recent years
sharing in september 2018 that he had
spent three months in a los
angeles hospital following surgery to
repair a gastrointestinal perforation
he has also previously battled alcohol
and vicodin addiction
of course the friends reunion marked the
first time the cast had all been
together on the set of the hit sitcom
since the show wrapped 17 years ago and
matthew got emotional
talking about their tight bond even
decades after the show first aired in
1994.
the best way that i can describe it is
after the show was
over at a party or any any kind of
social gathering
if one of us bumped into each other that
was it that was the end of the night
you just sat with them sat with the
person
all night long and all that echoes what
the cast told e.t
leading up to the big reunion from the
first table read of the pilot without
having met
any of the others beforehand we all felt
kind of an instant chemistry
going way back all i can say is that
there was something
that was laid down at the very very
beginning that kind of went into our
neural pathways that we
instantly it was in our dna that we were
family we were going to take care of
each other
it's unexplainable but we're the most
grateful
women that i know who have been able to
be a part of something like this
you